Donald Trump says he actually has a plan
for how to make Mexico pay for his wall
he even wrote it down and he assures us
the whole thing will only take three
days but like many things Trump says the
plan is overly simplistic tinged with
racism and full of inconsistencies
here's the idea on his first day in
office the Trump administration would
propose to change a rule in the Patriot
Act that would make wire transfer
companies like Western Union check
people's legal status before they open
an account or wire money the idea is to
prevent cash flow from working
immigrants to their families back home
here's the first problem the rule he'd
cited in his plan doesn't even exist
anymore it changed five years ago and is
now called something different minor
detail though right
if Trump did figure out which a lot of
change the implications stretch further
than just Mexico it would impact
immigrants of any legal status from
sending money anywhere in the world on
day two
Trump expects Mexico will protest he
thinks Mexico gets so much money from
immigrants wiring cash back home we give
Mexico fortune that if he threatens to
stop that flow it'll force the
government of Mexico to cave in and pay
for the wall that brings us to day three
of Trump's America when he tells Mexico
that he won't actually change this rule
if Mexico agrees to pay for the wall his
argument is that Mexico gets 24 billion
dollars per year from people
transferring money out of the u.s.
specifically illegal aliens as he calls
them Trump says that if Mexico wants to
keep getting that 24 billion dollars a
year they should just hand over five to
ten billion dollars to build the wall
but in reality there's no evidence that
the majority of that money is coming
from undocumented immigrants and experts
think that Trump's wall could cost
closer to twenty five billion dollars oh
and one more thing the people Trump is
insisting will pay for the wall have
this to say I repeat what I've said
personally mr. Trump Mexico will never
pay for a wall the former Mexican
President had even stronger words I'm
not gonna pay for that
whoa so this is what a detailed Trump
plan looks like good luck with that
you